hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar procalcitonin PCT Catalyst and
antibiotic stewardship I am Megan Pascal
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Abbott to learn more visit
corelaboratory.abit.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them in the ask a question box and
click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Dr James F newenschwander Emergency
Physician at Doctors Hospital in
Columbus Ohio
Dr neuenschwander you may now begin your
presentation
hello I'm Jim new and schwander I'm an
attending physician at Doctors Hospital
in Columbus Ohio in the United States
I'm also an adjunct associate professor
at the Ohio State University I'm really
happy that you could all join us today I
know you're coming in from all over the
world Central and South America Europe
maybe some places in Asia Canada I just
want to thank you all for taking time to
talk about this
um this is the first time I've done this
presentation to an international
audience so I thought about maybe
spicing it up a little bit changing my
hair singing and dancing uh something
like that and then I remembered
um I can't sing or dance so I'm just
going to make it as um
fun for you as possible I was gonna
um say
chocolate is one of the wonderful things
in all of life that we look at and what
I'd love to have you all do is put in
the chat box what country you're in and
your favorite chocolate uh from your
country my favorite chocolate is
actually not from the US I'm going to
disclose that later in the middle of the
talk and hope that you stay tuned uh
just for complete transparency I am
videotaping this before so I will be
able to read your comments in the chat
so don't be afraid to put those in there
so what we're going to talk about today
is
procalcitonin news in 2022 how are we
using it how does it benefit us as
practitioners how do we care for our
patients better these are my disclosures
and these are the objectives today we're
going to discuss procalcitonin
antibacterial stewardship and sepsis and
lower respiratory tract infections
illustrate the impact of procalcitonin
on emergency department and ICU decision
making
and also demonstrate the economic
benefits of procalcitonin which are
numerous
so let's go back all the way to 2018 BC
also known as before covid that's what
the BC stands for and one of the cases
that I first started using uh
procalcitonin as a test about three or
four years ago
and so I'm kind of a neophyte in the U.S
because there are people that have been
doing this far longer than me and yet
um this is one of the first cases and I
think it's a great case so if you
haven't picked up procast attorney yet
don't be embarrassed there's still time
to use it if you've been using it for a
while hopefully this case will help
illustrate some things that will be
helpful to you and this was a very sweet
90 year old female that came to my
emergency department because I'm an ER
doctor she had a history of hypertension
reactive airway disease she had recently
been in the hospital for bronchitis
about three weeks to a month before uh
and now she was coming it was shortness
of breath and a cough and her pulse
oximetry was low
so
her vital signs are as follows 183 over
79 was her blood pressure heart rate was
73 respiratory rate was an honest 20
times a minute temperature of 97.9 and
her pulse ox was 89 percent on Romero we
got a chest x-ray which showed a new
linear opacity in the right lung base
um suggestive of subsequental
atelectasis or an infiltrate and so
basically I had a
nine-year-old woman with um a pneumonia
that was bouncing back within UH 60 days
of the time she had last been in the
hospital so I did what I felt was safe
at that time again not horribly
comfortable with procalcitonin I gave
her Hospital acquired Community or
excuse me hospital acquired pneumonia
antibiotics through the IV and I put her
in the hospital I did grow draw a
procalcitonin and on day three they
checked another procalcitonin Each of
which were low and on day four it was
still low
for RSV positive she was RSV positive
um on day four that popped and so the
antibiotics were stopped and this is a
great example of hey we can start
antibiotics at the clinical picture is
concerning and even though we had a low
procalcitonin we waited we checked the
procalcitones they stayed low so this
was a viral pneumonia
a two-week follow-up her physician
ordered a uh CT scan of her chest
without IV contrast
um one of the embarrassing elements of
why Healthcare is so expensive in the
United States I don't know why he didn't
just order a repeat chest x-ray but he
got a CT scan and I did give him a
little bit of grief about that and said
hey Billy why you got to get a CT scan
you're just checking on pneumonia and he
said well I also wanted to take a look
at making sure that her pneumonia had
resolved and she had a wedge fracture on
T6 so I wanted to take a look at that
nonetheless the bottom line was that she
did very well at follow-up she didn't
need antibiotics for her pneumonia and
that's where procalcitonin comes in a
lot of times for us is saying hey
there's a pneumonia on x-ray do I really
need antibiotics in this situation and
in this case she didn't need them we
stopped them and she did very well in
follow-up
so how does broke acetone work well
there's these toll-like receptors on the
um surface of cells and when those are
stimulated by in this cartoon a green
looking glob of bacteria in this case
there are messages that are then sent
and il1 tnf il-6 are stimulated and then
released into the blood system the
challenge with these signals is that
they're sometimes blocked by medications
disease processes so they don't always
helpful to us
so what happens with procalcitonin
though is that it is
um transcribed translated and then
released back into the blood system in a
manner that is similar to the amount of
the severity of the back
so in other words if there's a lot of
bacteria that are stimulating the cell
surfaces then we get a large amount of
procalcitonin released which is very
helpful to us if there's a lot of
procalcitonin then we're going to think
hey there's a big bacterial burden and
this is somebody that needs antibiotics
and then I'm going to follow their
procalcitonin to make sure that it's
actually coming down and that the
antibiotics I'm utilizing
are effective in fighting this disease
so in also in a schematic form here uh
we can see that if somebody comes in
after the procalcitonin is peaked which
usually takes about 24 hours or so so in
the first three hours
I don't know what people are like in
Central South America Canada and other
places but generally people don't sneeze
and then run into the emergency
department so in those first three to
six hours that somebody's infected
um we're not going to see a big peak of
procalcitonin but most people wait to
come to the hospital and about 12 to 24
hours if we have somebody that comes in
that has a procalcitonin of 10 and then
we treat them with antibiotics and we
see that their procalcitonin has come
down uh in the next 48 hours 24 to 48
hours then we know the antibiotics that
we're utilizing are very effective
what situations though do we see
procalcitonin elevated when it's not a
bacterial infection and procalcitonin is
a thinking test we can't just look at it
like a pregnancy test you're either
pregnant or you're not pregnant right
procalcitonin is more like a troponin a
high sensitivity troponin
um where in some cases it might be a
little bit elevated if somebody has some
renal failure
or they have sepsis or some other other
element for troponin so you have to kind
of think about I have to think about
procasatonin in the right setting there
are some physiologic stressors like
severe trauma surgery cardiogenic shock
and burns can give you a little bump in
procalcitonin in the absence of a
bacterial infection there is some gut
trans dislocation that occurs so you'll
see little bumps of procalcites on in in
the uh
um events of some of these other
physiological uh stressors if we draw
the procalcitonin too early sometimes
it'll be falsely low in the uh in the
uh event of a bacterial infection and
it's not great for localized infections
abscesses skin infections I wish I could
have it when people come in and they
always seem to blame spiders in the
United States when they have a red mark
on their arm and they go I think a
spider bit me and it's hard to tell
sometimes is that a localized allergic
reaction or do you have an infection
um you know is this allergic or is it
infection
procasitonin is not great for that uh
also not great for otitis media and when
a little guy comes in or little gal
comes in and we're looking to see if
they have an uh otitis media
procalcitonin would not be great in that
um setting
unfortunately
um there's also a couple of cancers that
can give us some elevated
procalcitonin's medullary thyroid cancer
small uh cell lung cancer many times we
already know that they have those
disease States
um and so it doesn't throw us off very
well and again chronic kidney disease
and um acute kidney injury can give us
some elevation in procalcitonin levels
um likewise in the first 48 Hours 72
hours of Life uh little ones can have a
little bump in their procalcitonin after
about that first week though
um certainly we have seen a good amount
of it used in a pediatric setting
all right here's my
God I told you I would disclose my
favorite chocolate this is my this is
one of my favorite chocolates I don't
know that anybody truly has one favorite
chocolate well this is one of my
favorite chocolates and it's actually
from Italy so
if you uh have a put in your uh the
country you're from and the chocolate
that is your favorite now you can just
put your favorite not just from the
chocolate from the country you're in but
your favorite chocolate whatever that be
um please let us know all right so this
is uh some ICU randomized controlled
trials comparing procalcitone and guided
algorithm antibiotic Administration as
opposed to just standard of care and
what did we see
well I see you in intensive care units
um will uh adapt these protocols and we
saw that the uh places that adopted the
procalcitonin algorithms
actually had a positive impact on
mortality and reduced antibiotic
duration that's really important when we
look at all the data from these
different studies that indicates listen
get the diagnosis right from the
beginning and patients don't have to be
exposed to antibiotics they don't need
and they can get the therapy they need
I'll give you an example
when I asked somebody come in that has a
cough and maybe a low-grade temperature
and they have a history of CHF and I
look at the X-ray and I see bilateral
infiltrates I ask myself is this heart
failure and pneumonia or is this just
heart failure in cases where
microcalcitonin is low and in many I
think in these cases as well when we say
you know what it is just heart failure
diary stem get them tuned up don't
poison them with antibiotics they don't
need what we see is that patients get
through the hospital more rapidly and
have less exposure to antibiotics and
then have better outcomes and that's not
surprising for those of us that have
been utilizing procalcitonin for a while
so where do I like to use procalcitonin
well shortness of breath
it's the differential diagnosis for
shortness of breath is very long CHF Mi
pericardite is valvular disease
cardiomyopathy and I'm going to go
through this list because I think it's
really important
does anybody know the differential
diagnosis for orthopedic surgery
very simple bone broke bone not broke
I mean how hard can that be so for me
when I'm looking at patients with
shortness of breath I'm asking myself
you know could this be COPD asthma
bronchitis pneumonia Airway obstruction
could they have a pulmonary embolism
could they have anemia that's causing it
carbon monoxide poisoning
hyperventilation covid
pneumothorax cardiac tamponade there's
so many reasons why people can feel
short of breath and another place that I
use it is when they come in and they
can't give me a lot of history like a
nursing home patient this case number
two was a patient that came in we
weren't sure she was a psychiatric
patient or what the situation was
um she had a psych history she was 59
years old with a history of depression
and anxiety brought to the emergency
department after being seen walking
around agitated and talking to herself
couldn't give me a lot of history I just
got a little bit of a cough I don't know
what that means is that maybe she you
know she's encephalopathic because of
some infection or is she just simply
having a psychotic break
I looked at her Vital Signs and her
heart rate was 121. that didn't bring me
any great comfort respiratory rate of 20
temperature of 98.2 pulse X was 100
which made me feel good and more likely
to think well she may not necessarily be
infected
um I mean because she's not hypoxic she
does have a fever wait and you see that
and her BMI
previous chart after I ordered all the
tests I went back and looked and saw
that she actually had a history of uh
tachycardia almost all the time and her
heart rate on the last visit was 109
which was about her Baseline I still had
to work her up though in case she was
infected and I got a chest x-ray I had
CT CBC BMP uh CMP rather UA EKG and her
procalcitonein all of which were normal
lactate was 3.3 so again I I couldn't
completely rule out an infection so I
gave her some IV fluids and rechecked
her lactate and it was 0.8 and probably
your lactate was up because she had been
eating very well uh because of her
psychosis I admitted her to Psychiatry
and she did very well those of you that
practice in the U.S or other places when
you know we don't want to send sick
people to a psychiatric ward many times
at least in the U.S if they decompensate
they're farther away from the rest of
the hospital the medical care they get
is somewhat compromised uh in in the
event of um just being on a psych ward
our medical team doesn't necessarily
round on them so I am always really
really cognizant not to send somebody to
psychiatric Wards if I have any concern
that they're sick pro-calcitonia was a
huge huge portion of my recognizing that
she was not infected in that case so
what's our protocol 0.1 to 0.25
bacterial infection is very unlikely
antibiotics are definitely discouraged
in that setting 0.26 to 0.5 bacterial
infection is much more likely
antibiotics are encouraged in that
setting and again where I see somebody
with bilateral infiltrates in their
procalciton is 0.5 much more likely I'm
going to start that patient on some
antibiotics and give them another
therapy I feel like they need for that
current setting
it's 0.51 and above bacterial infection
is very likely and much more
suggestive of a bacterial infection and
antibiotics are strongly encouraged in
that setting
all right so again uh for the rest of
the world if you don't understand I'm an
Ohio State guy from Columbus Ohio uh
imagine in your country your favorite
football team soccer team whatever
sporting team it is
um and then imagine your most uh hated
rival your biggest rivalry competitor
and multiply that times three and you
have a feeling of what it's like for
Ohio State and the University of
Michigan
sadly
the University of Michigan and us have
exactly the same protocol for
procalcitonin and this year in the
Rivalry they did or they did win last
year the big game is coming up this year
um
it mirrors their uh treatment of
patients which again just shows us no
matter what uh if somebody has a low Pro
calcitonin they probably don't need
antibiotics if they do get higher then
certainly antibiotics seem to fit and
even in Michigan when you have a high
procasitone and you should definitely
get antibiotics all right that's a
little tongue-in-cheek we really have
several friends at the University of
Michigan one of my nieces is there it's
a great institution uh but I just wanted
to illustrate that there is a great deal
of uniformity among practitioners in the
U.S then one of the other strong points
of procalcitonin is that
when the procalcitonin level comes down
less than 0.25 or 80 percent of the
original value so again if it starts at
10 and then it comes down to point or
excuse me it comes down to two it's
decreased by 80 percent we can stop the
antibiotics I know how we ever all
bought into this concept that everybody
needs 10 days of antibiotics or two
weeks of antibiotics including you know
those people with hypertension diabetes
heart failure
um
are in their 70s and 80s compared to the
20 year old who has no comorbidities
um you can't tell me that those two uh
population groups are the same so one of
the nice things about procalcitona is it
helps us truncate when it's safe to stop
antibiotics and that's really important
so it helps us in determining when to
start and then when we can stop on
patients and that's why we check them
about every 24 to 48 hours once somebody
gets in the hospital
all right so how did we adopt
procassetonin in um
our little hospital so I was at a
conference and I picked up some
information on procalcitonin I thought
this looks pretty cool talked to some
people that were using it and this is
around 2017 or so and I dropped it off
with the lab and just kind of left it at
that
um they talked to our laboratory talked
to Pharmacy and others is particularly
those in the antibiotic stewardship
um committee and Pharmacy said
excuse me yeah hey let's do this this
makes sense
how can we give practitioners a better
way to determine whether somebody needs
antibiotics and then how long they need
antibiotics
the company represented uh
Representatives then came out and
started to teach us which was
interesting because the next time I
really thought about this is
um Amy Farley was out given a lecture at
our hospital and I said wow this is
really great stuff and so I started
using it and
um I we produced a CME lecture that went
on to our clinical uh our computer-based
learning so that people could look at
um the education at any time day or
night I understand my talk was utilized
for people that couldn't sleep at night
uh and they would say hey just watch
anyone who want to talk on procasta tone
and it's a cure for insomnia
just kidding although I it was you know
Mighty if it helped with that that's
fine nonetheless we did have education
at our site uh both from the company and
ourselves and then we started to talk
about it we had to put a dock at triage
we were so overwhelmed uh during covet
that we would put docs out of triage and
many times that they were coming in
short of breath we would push in you
know chest x-ray CDC BMP troponin BNP
procalcitonin and by the time they did
get a room in the back if the
processantona was negative and they were
coveted positive many of those folks we
were sending home and I'll share with
you some of the data that we based that
on
all right so how do we use it in the
emergency department from Time Zero we
ask ourselves is there shortness of
breath and infection or could it be
something else
is there mental status change from an
infection or maybe it's from something
else
is there covet likely to get worse or is
their prognosis good and again the lower
your procasitonin is with covid the
better your prognosis
the higher your pro your pro constantona
with covid the worse your prognosis so
that was one of the elements that we
were utilizing to figure out whether to
put somebody in the hospital and it
hasn't really changed even though we
don't see as much covet right now we
certainly
um use it in other along with other
viral infections and in particularly
with pneumonia and it provides
procasitonin provides a level for
tracking in the hospital
all right this is another great case uh
it was actually sent to me by a friend
we were chatting about it and I said
that is really a great uh example of how
to use process Pro calcitonin so she
sent it to me it was at their Hospital
43 year old female with a history of
pulmonary arterial hypertension uh she's
on continuous oxygen at home she came to
the emergency department for increasing
shortness of breath and cough
uh there are her vital signs at the
bottom Tampa 99.5 heart rate of 121
respiratory rate of 17 blood pressure a
little softer from the beginning 95 over
50 in her O2 sat was 98 and already she
was on a 40 Vinnie mask
um her Labs came back covered positive
white blood cell count was what we would
expect in covet 3.8 platelets 111.
procal was negative and this is
important again you need antibiotics and
uh she didn't get any antibiotics which
uh is not surprising lactic acid she
wasn't real acidotic 0.7
but as typical for so many of these
patients
um she didn't have a lot of respiratory
reserve and decompensated that day
needed to be intubated uh day two she
was hypotensive she needed to um and she
spiked a fever she required three
different uh pressers levofed dobutamine
and vasopressin to maintain a map of 65
and anytime you're on three pressers
that's a bad day uh she began being
prone for about 16 hours a day day 14.
it was a long time on event they check
another procalcitonin and it's 3.82 they
start antibiotics and unfortunately as
you can see the CPR and that last little
box there
um she died on day 17 which is
unfortunate because what we have to ask
ourselves and this is where we like to
utilize it in the hospital is every 24
to 48 hours get a procalcitone in on day
14 her prokostatonin was three point A2
so what day was it that she started
probably needing antibiotics probably I
would estimate day seven maybe day eight
had they done a procalcitonin at that
time could she have received antibiotics
and lived I don't know that we'll ever
know but it certainly makes sense in the
inpatient setting to be checking this on
either daily or every other day basis to
see if somebody's developed a new
pneumonia
that's now bacterial instead of just the
viral pneumonia that they came in with
so bacterial co-infections are a
significant risk factor in covid-19
patients and we can put that in with
influenza A B RSV whatever fill in the
blank
virus you want to say and I was talking
to a colleague of mine the other day and
I said you know that's where procastone
is very helpful you have you know have
about half of all pneumonias are
bacterial half are viral and if it's
just viral then
um they tend to do much better and if
it's viral and bacterial they do worse
and she said Oh you mean two two types
of pneumonia are worse than one so it's
kind of a little smart alec remark but
at the same time it really is accurate
if you have a viral antibacterial
infection which a lot of viral
infections set us up for as a bacterial
infection yes absolutely that's worse
and so this was looking uh as a
meta-analysis from 14 different studies
about 3 500 patients bacterial
co-infections in about 4.7 to 19.5 of
all cases and about 90 of those patients
with severe or a fatal course
had co-bacterial infections and the odds
ratio if you look down there at the
bottom and that bottom uh right hand box
with the red lines around it that your
odds ratio was as high as
20.8 with an elevated procalcitonin so
we don't have crystal balls we don't
have we can't always read the future I
wish I had a crystal ball and could read
the um who could read the future the
bottom line is procalcitonin can help us
predict who's going to do well and who
is not and these studies actually are
some very good evidence to support that
so
again
how does it help uh in the hospital to
discharge sometimes if we uh antibiotics
are started and then stopped which is
great you know when I first started I
probably started way more antibiotics
and my partners stopped him now when I
get somebody with like a COPD
exacerbation and I ask them hey what do
we usually do for you uh when you have
to come in the hospital and they say
well
I need uh steroids
breathing treatments I need that one
pain medicine that starts with the D uh
delala dilantined Dilaudid that's it and
some antibiotics
um now I know in Central South America
Europe Asia the places that that I'm
talking to and especially in Canada you
don't have pain you don't have patients
asking for pain medicines
um but unfortunately in the US many
times we do so when I do put copders in
and I've used the procalcitone and
that's low I can tell them you're right
we're going to give you steroids we're
going to give you breathing treatments
and your procalcitone is low so we don't
need to poison you with antibiotics
and you don't need Dilaudid
um
and there are some cases then that we
stop sometimes antibiotics are not
started but then with their COPD it gets
worse in the hospital and then sometimes
they'll add in the antibiotics later and
sometimes we start antibiotics in the
emergency department and they're not
working and then we change them all
right so let's talk about the economics
because that's always you know when
things come down to it
where's the cheese how are we going to
get this into our Hospital the one of
the ways that we looked at this was how
much money could we save by using
procalcitonin instead of giving
antibiotics
so this was a cost impact of procasseton
and guided antibiotic stewardship versus
usual care for hospitalized patients
with suspected sepsis for lower
respiratory tract infections in the U.S
a health economic model analysis and
basically what they were looking at is
they were comparing the effectiveness
and costs of procalcitonin algorithm
versus standard of care to guide
antibiotic prescriptions in patients
hospitalized with diagnosis of suspected
sepsis or lower respiratory tract
infections again a U.S study and if you
want to translate this into your
countries remember U.S citizens most of
us are mammals so this data should
definitely translate to whatever country
you're in and what did they see
the cost impact of procalcitone and
guided antibiotic stewardship versus
usual care showed that antibiotic days
using procalcitonin were reduced by 5.8
so again we could see those patients
that didn't need any antibiotics and
didn't give them antibiotics the the
episodes of C diff were decreased for a
cost Savings of over sixteen thousand
dollars
I was down in Houston and I was giving a
talk I think it was for part of the
antibiotic stewardship week and I stood
up and I said hey
how many people hate the smell of C diff
and almost everybody raised their hand
and I said if you want less C diff quit
using someone and I dropped the mic and
dropped and said that's it that's my
whole talk
all right so it's not quite that easy of
course but
you want less C diff
give patients less antibiotics very
simple equation and we know that it's a
cost savings to the hospital of about
sixteen thousand dollars every time we
don't give somebody C diff and many
times that comes by not giving somebody
antibiotics they don't need we save
about 330 bucks uh a patient that on
antibiotics uh mechanical ventilation
for those patients again that we get the
diagnosis right on uh we'll save about
twenty one hundred dollars with
procalcitonin as opposed to usual care
um 86 in lab testing so you say well oh
we're doing electricity lab tests this
means that we're going to do more lab
testing procasitonin is not a very
expensive lab test uh I don't want to
say uh the price for your countries
because I really don't know but in the
U.S most of the times it's less than
twenty dollars so I don't know how that
translates into yours but
um I can get a couple of burritos and um
some soft drinks here in the U.S uh for
less than 20 bucks for my beautiful wife
and I
so the overall cost savings per patient
was over 11
000 for patients that had pro-calcitonin
guided antibiotic stewardship again uh
this is the cost impact of patients uh
usual care for hospitalized patients
suspected sepsis for lower respiratory
tract infections
um another meta-analysis also showed
antibiotic days were about five days
Thirty One Thousand in the C diff area
antibiotics about 290 very similar
numbers vents excuse me
um mechanical ventilation uh 221 dollars
again these were less ill patients so
not as many of them were on the vent lab
testing a little bit more uh in the
procalcitonin group and saved over 2
868 so again these are patients that
were not in the ICU but even if we're
using it for non-icu patients you're
still saving uh close to 2 800 bucks
which is a big cost savings to us uh in
the United States on a patient so again
review
um
we wanted to discuss procalcitonin
antibiotic stewardship and sepsis and
lower respiratory tract infections
illustrate the impact of procalcitonin
on emergency department
um and ICU decision making and
demonstrate the economic benefits of
procalcitonin so that is uh the end of
my formal presentation if you didn't get
your favorite chocolate or whatever your
chocolate is please throw that in the
chat along with whatever questions you
have I'll be happy to answer those and
once again folks thank you so much for
your time I really appreciate this
opportunity thank you for Abbott for
sponsoring this
um learning uh venue and I hope that we
can talk soon
have a great day everybody
thank you so much Dr newenschwander for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
left of your screen we will answer as
many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can procalcitonin be elevated without
infection
yes uh there are some places where we
will see Pro Castleton and be up a
little bit uh such as surgery trauma
Burns
um with some gut trans dislocation there
are certain cancers that can do that
thyroid
um cancer can and there are some lung
cancers that can as well I generally
those numbers are not very high and
don't have a great impact and oftentimes
we already know that those conditions
are present so it's again just putting
it in that context and utilizing um that
information
great thank you our next question is
what can falsely Elevate procalcitonin
or falsely decreased false negative
um so sometimes it can look like a false
negative if it's too early in the course
like if somebody comes in before
um it's had a Peak at 24 hours and so we
can see it falsely low uh some of those
other things that we talked about
previously we can see it elevated a tad
in
um or we can see it elevated in Burns
trauma uh abdominal surgeries
and those are really the things to take
into considerations localized affections
cellulitis may not bump procalcitonin
even in the um presence of a bacterial
infection and endocarditis is another
place that disappointingly doesn't have
a big increase in procalcitonin
awesome our next question
is how long does broke
stay elevated
good question uh it starts to go up in
about two to six hours and it stays
elevated for 24 hours if we treat it
with an appropriate antibiotic we'll
start to see it come down within that 24
hour range but generally we can see it
Peak and hang around in about 24 hours
so about a day about a day
great our next question is which
inflammatory marker is better CRP or
procalcitonin
uh CRP takes longer to go up it's not as
specific uh or as sensitive for
bacterial infections so I Gotta Give the
nod to procalcitonin in this case
um it is uh certainly the one I go to
there are certain things I like a CRP
for if I'm worried about a joint
infection something like that
it certainly seems to be a good place
for it
um
Pediatrics uh with appendicitis yet
overall the vast majority of the time
when I'm trying to differentiate between
a viral versus a bacterial infection and
why I want to know that is that I know
about 50 of all pneumonias are viral
right and so what is one nice thing that
covid gave us was that when I talked to
patients and I say listen this is a
virus it is not going to respond to
antibiotics because antibiotics are um
medicine or poison to kill bugs and it's
like bug spray and and covet and all
these other viruses are more like
elephants right
and if you spray an elephant with bug
spray it's not going to do anything so
we don't need to spray your viral
infection with bug spray it's a virus we
have other treatments for it you don't
need antibiotics
great
uh how do high levels oh wait sorry
um yes how do high levels of
procalcitonin interfere with calcitonin
levels or vice versa
wait say it again how does it affect
calcium levels of procalcitone and
interfere with calcitonin levels or vice
versa they actually don't interfere with
calcitonin levels so if there was a
reason that you were checking that
um there certainly wouldn't be any
interference from procalcitonin
great thank you
um are there any POC point-of-care
analyzers used right in ed in the USA
boy I wish there were uh to be perfectly
fair I don't know of any that do but it
would be nice to have that back
particularly like we get plenty of
people that just come in and they're
like coveted positive they come to the
emergency department and they need a
work excuse or they need to
um be evaluated a quick uh procasitonin
in that case would be awesome and
there's other people that come in and
they you know they've been sick for a
week with a bronchitis or potentially an
atypical pneumonia I would love to just
do a finger stick and get a pro
calcitonin on them but I am not aware of
any
um point of care testing that's a great
idea if you come up with the idea let me
know because I want to buy it and use it
great thank you and it looks like our
last question for today
um we know that PCT levels can be
elevated in patients with acute or
chronic renal failure or on dialysis how
do you elevate PCT when managing these
patients so yeah anyway
you're doing great you're doing great
um yeah that's a we actually you know we
did a study at our shop where we looked
at patients that anybody that got
Vancomycin automatically had a
procalcatonin level drawn and then we
had the pharmacy team which are the
antibiotic stewards follow it so if you
started low and continued low they would
call the doc and go Hey listen it was
low from the beginning it's still low
now do we really need the antibiotics
and most the docs said no we don't uh we
even did that with end-stage renal
disease patients and we had some
patients that came in and their
procalcitonin levels were low despite
the fact that they didn't clear it as
well because of their end-stage renal
disease or were on
um dialysis
and then we had some people that came in
and their procal level would be one and
then it just stayed one and it was flat
so what we saw was that if you can have
a baseline for people that have
end-stage renal disease that you can
actually follow the trend if it's going
up then certainly then the concern for a
bacterial infection is greater
um if it's going down and you've given
antibiotics and they seem to be working
but if it's flat then there's a pretty
good chance you're not dealing with I
don't know if that was completely flat
did that look like it went across flat I
was watching
um but if it stays flat then the
likelihood is you're probably dealing
with a virus so I still want to do that
study I've been trying to talk Thermo
and Abbott into letting me do a study
where I draw
um procalcitonins on patients undergoing
hemodialysis and then follow them for a
year while they're in the hospital and
just see what their procalcitonin levels
do so that is helpful in the setting of
um end-stage rental disease or kidney
failure patients but again more or as a
trend than as a single number
great and it looks like we have a few
more questions coming in here how do you
look at patients with possible possible
atypical pneumonia or low procalcitonin
levels do you consider false negative
levels in this case
so atypical pneumonias uh so if you get
like a mycoplasma they'll still have a
little bump in their procal it's
sometimes you know we've looked at
studies Dr self did a study of over a
thousand patients and when they looked
at atypical pneumonias they were still
between 0.25 and 0.5 on average so you
do see a little bit of a bump
considering the fact that .25 is kind of
that base level that I'll start using
um
procalcitonin as far as false uh
negatives
um again the clinical picture when I see
a COPD here and they have you know gross
yellow sputum and they're having uh you
know other symptoms that might make me
think of an atypical pneumonia then
certainly in that situation but I got to
tell you the majority of times uh when
they're having those symptoms where
they're bringing up you know um darker
sputum and things like that I do find
that they're procasitonin levels are up
um and those are the folks that I go
ahead and give antibiotics to
great and are there critical levels
considered for PCT
yeah I mean I think that you know
anytime you get above uh 1.0 you have to
be concerned about sepsis right I mean
and that's what everybody's concerned
about is sepsis how worried should I be
about this person who's sitting in front
of me right now eating a bag of Doritos
on their cell phone
um and they may not look that bad but
the procalcitonin level is up and you go
this is a bad marker or this is a marker
for you to do poorly
um so in those levels where uh or when I
do see those levels above 0.5 I get much
more concerned that somebody is going to
get septic and get into a lot of trouble
uh very soon down the line and I don't
want to send them home and start my
shift the next day or two and somebody
goes hey do you remember that person you
sent home the other day their broke
acetone was 0.6 and I go oh no and I
find out that they came back and now
they're uh hospitalized or have a
breathing tube and uh and I feel awful
so when I see those numbers High those
are kind of critical numbers for me
those are again markers for me that this
patient could indeed have something
that's going to pretend a bad outcome
for them
great thank you
end of our q a for today
um do you have any final comments for
our audience
hey thanks for all the comments about
the chocolate
um you know that was my daughter's idea
to put in the chat and find out she
actually took a course at Ohio State I
paid for it
um on a chocolate the whole class was
just chocolate and she said I want to
hear about uh the different type of
chocolates around the world so we hope
to come visit you in Argentina and we
saw some others from Finland and other
countries some of the language I
couldn't ever understand but I did
screenshot these and uh we can't wait to
um come try out some of these different
chocolates in these different places
around the world so thanks everybody for
participating uh if you want we could
certainly send you a list of some of the
great chocolates so you can have that
too and if you want any other
information on procassetonin we'll be
happy to get that to you as well again
thanks to AVID for sponsoring this and
lab roots for doing such an excellent
job and we're grateful to everybody for
joining us today and that's all for me
awesome thank you again Dr Newen
schwander for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
they're interesting questions questions
we do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time bye
hey everybody